two days after his sudden arrest a
sudden turnaround for Imran Khan
the Supreme Court ruling it was illegal
and ordering his release but the
government can't see the problem do you
have faith in your Supreme Court as an
institution yes as individuals I have
questions are you suggesting that the
Supreme Court
as I said as I said Supreme Court as an
institution I'm not saying anything
because there are Judges I'm talking
about the individuals and the perception
when such orders are made I can after
the order it is my constitutional right
to analyze the order to discuss the
order to cite the order or to criticize
the order would you like to see Mr Khan
detained tomorrow
well it's it's up to the court as I said
the government is not part of this
arrest it's a national accountability uh
Bureau the court and the Islamabad High
Court let's see what Islamabad High
Court does tomorrow do you recognize
that there are peaceful people that
believe
the way that Imran Khan was arrested was
unlawful unacceptable a stain on the
country I did not see those peaceful
peoples on the streets in last three
days there are ways to arrest someone
tell me calmly tell me no no no a person
no the person as I said a person who
defies law of the land uh and it if if
it's not Imran Khan if it's anybody I
ask you the question in your country
also a conduct of a person is as such
what will the police do
now the case goes to the high court
which must decide whether to Grant bail
so the stage is set for another dramatic
chapter in the Imran Khan story he has a
night at least to enjoy some freedom to
Rally his troops and to decide on his
next steps but we've seen how quickly
that freedom can be taken away
in this tense climate it's hard to
imagine any result will go unchallenged
Pakistan